this is the upper body that I prepared
for television not thrilled I want huge
muscles I don't know why I'm handling
most public doors fine but the desire is
there the only problem is I know that if
I want them I have to go to the gym
which I can't do because I hate it
because everybody else that goes is very
good at it and that's not fair like I
want to work out next to people who are
amazing right because I just feel bad
that I'm in their way they all came with
a plan and a tank top protein shake and
a note pad what are you writing down
everything was heavy again also like
free weights dumbbells somehow they will
know what weight they need at the
beginning of the exercise ok I need the
45s now how do you know that already I
don't know what weight I need until I
try to pick up all the ones that are
heavier than that one and can't that's
how I narrow it down start at one end
like no no no or sometimes over this
move pick one up sit down do one curl be
like mm nope not going the distance on
that but even if you don't like the gym
people won't take that as an excuse to
be out of shape like oh you don't like
the gym why don't you just run
you should try running it's outside and
it's free
yeah it's also the hardest thing in the
world
have you tried running for longer than
one adult minute it's very difficult
like running is the only activity I have
ever done where the entire time you are
doing it your own brain is going hey
stop this right now
nothing is chasing us and we're not
hungry that's why I think people who are
good at running we got really cocky
about it try to bring it up all the time
what do you do on the runner
that's your job no I just want you to
know that I do it a lot like I would
never classify myself as a runner I'm
still at jogger status I'd like to
upgrade I don't know how it happens I
know you don't want to be a jogger
though because everything bad in the
news always happens to a jogger the news
a tree fell over on a jogger today many
runners hurt no they ran out of the way
well gentlemen to cook right now because
I never learned before I moved out which
was mistake my mom tried to teach me but
I was very arrogant about it I was like
I don't doing this now I don't where the
grocery store is I'll figure it out and
then I tried that and realized that you
can't because if you don't know how to
cook you also don't know how to shop
because ingredients are not together in
the grocery store the grocery store is a
place where someone has disassembled
foods and hid the pieces all over a
building
so then I have to walk around a
warehouse trying to reverse-engineer
tacos from memory it's very difficult so
if I ever took a girl out on a date I
would have to go to a restaurant and I'd
always pay for things on a first date I
know a lot of guys get upset about that
right there was like why should I have
to buy her a salads she's got a job
equal rights and I kind of used to
understand where they were coming from
and then I discovered how much make up
costs and now I will pay for everything
all the time because it's like a secret
you still kind of keep making up a
secret and it's usually the answer to
all the stupid questions guys have about
you like 11 ever guys like why is taking
so long in the bathroom
girls take so long in there yeah she has
to build a face in there so hard that is
I can't even draw a face on a piece of
paper you have to take your time because
it's so expensive it's like $100 for
this big of a box and that's for this
part of your eyes
the cannot even the whole eye is covered
half the lid is $100 and every girl is
wearing it you can't not buy that
because if you go out of the house
without that on if you're gonna come at
you in the street we like what's wrong
with that part of your eye man you look
so tired you're gonna be like shut up I
had to pay for my own salad thank you so
much
you